yeah hello welcome to this video yeah
this will be a short video showing a
game from the concluded down european
club cap concluded yesterday the day
they were also in the last round it was
played in in islet in israel and this is
really a super strong competition the
european club cap i played this last
year with my dutch team and it really
was a great experience simply because it
was my father strong as he brenda ever
took pardon you had done like probably
20 30 players above 2,700 playing in
this event so basically every top layer
was there besides a the one that were
playing elsewhere and this yet was also
very strong it seems that the favorites
from other bajan so car won the event
super strong team just think about come
ski playing on board five he's got
rating of 2750 or something and he's
bought five and down they've got a
really huge team um but another thing
which is always great about those
tournament this those team tournaments
you've got also those uneven match ups
well sometimes um the big guys play yeah
sort of normal normal players and like
amateur players are good amateur players
they are not really every week players
there but I want to show you a game here
um with the German number one a car
denied each playing black his own 2700
play and the white players an
international master from Mott Cydonia
is rated slightly below 2400 so around
my my playing level but still 300 points
to the good for black so let's check
this game out
yeah what seems to go for catalan
opening but neither Chum yeah he's a
well-known fighter is not the kind of
person who wants to defend a slightly
worse position for for 460 moves against
a weaker player he wants to unbalance
the game so implies place c5 inviting a
transposition to have been only with v 5
which is accepted white can also decline
this by playing Knight f3 and then we
get very often kind of English Vinglish
opening position here black has some
interesting possibilities though it can
play d 50 all kinds of Queen moves
trying to harass the snide so but in the
game white plate d5 so we got a benoni
modern benoni wear white has played the
fianchetto variation all this looks
pretty normal and has been played to
hundreds of times ruki aid is also
normal move sometimes black also plays a
six first white plate Bishop f4 this is
um an interesting decision very often
why it's an automatic reaction to rookie
aid in these kind of structures is to
play Knight 2d to controlling the
foursquare so that 94 is not possible
anymore and very often the night of
course finds a useful square on c4 in
the game however wide to simply ignore
this an ID for you played Bishop f4 we
see that this looks too very peculiar
positions black first place night to a
six Queen to d2 probably intending on
Jan exchange of the bishops of Kosovo
and now like night c7 attacking d5
preparing b5 so rather normal and wider
place a form preventing this b5 idea and
now 94 this is exactly the point of the
set up with rook e8 early and white
worldwide ignores this we see what
happens
Black has got funnier Oconee for an
active rook but this now has nice ideas
lifting it to before with the tag on v2
this is also why black try to provoke a
for first for that you've got this
before square and probably black ISM is
very good in this position but I don't
want to get too deeply into this Y term
tries to exchange the strong Bishop and
black declines this yeah this is
understandable this is simply a
brilliant piece don't want to exchange
it and wide place not g5 an aggressive
move looking at those two pawns there's
not much happening at the moment but why
didn't see rookie for winning a tempo on
the Queen and now Bishop to d7 yeah
black trying to complete this
development he's got this idea of
queenie aid attacking this pawn this is
serve rather funny black in a Tekkit
very often it's it's not easy to do to
keep it so white played III rook before
but then take on b2 and white cover this
with rookie to yeah this is the kind of
move that shows that probably there's
something wrong with whites position he
couldn't really go rook be one because
then they for was just hanging so r uu k
29 to a six I in the square again so 11
ideas to to move the rook on let's to
introduce this night before possibility
let's say the rook at the moment doesn't
have really attractive square but it can
be technically useful to have this night
before available and f1 yeah this is the
kind of move you play if you notice that
your positionally yeah let's say a bus
there is a strong word but you're close
to positionally lost here that's why it
so you need to get something going you
cannot
just sit and wait until the 300 points
stronger player I'll place you on the
queenside or let's say you're already
out played on the queenside but just
wins the game down so white needs to get
going and he gets going with F warning
this is a very good practical decision
black now plays going to yet attacking
this pawn as mentioned this is an idea
and now this is very important and very
good um yeah practical advice or lesson
to learn if you're really bad bad in the
game you're you you've got problems
long-term and need to get in a tech
going you should really count pawns so
you played f5 the most aggressive move
available even if it's not one hundred
percent working at the move you should
play you shouldn't think about passive
defense like covering the spawn of
course you must cover it if it's simply
the only move available to do that but
this is an aggressive move and it's not
um yeah I immediately obvious how black
should review this in fact here it gets
very tricky let's have a look what would
happen if like take the porn it didn't
take it but let's let's have them as
well let's say black take the pond yeah
it's a check obviously so King edge one
it's the only move don't want to get
into a pin or exchange Queens and what
now black can has grabbed a spawn but
this is a really sensitive diagonal why
does threatening stuff like Knight takes
f7 with the discovery on the bishop on
the queen or taking on g6 it's not at
all easy to to play this position let's
say for instance Queen to e7 which looks
like a normal move returning and sort of
covering up things then white has a
really strong move with Bishop h3 this
is some not at all easy to find it's not
the only move that gives a strong attack
but this seems to be the strongest the
ideas if you look at this let's say we
should have six attacking this white can
take on g6
and after F takes g6 you've got Bishop
e6 check so this Bishop really nice
deactivated himself and here it gets
very difficult would like to keep this
position together probably he's already
clearly worse if black doesn't take on
e6 that gets very ugly cut them moves
like H form and then Queen f2 this is
really a really dangerous and white
always has not f7 to make a draw this
makes it even even worse from a
practical point of view for black so
it's a it's really dangerous Queenie 7sm
answered by this Bishop h3 move at least
them yeah at least very dangerous
probably good and let's say Queenie five
another idea attacking here and
strangling this then white can simply
take on g6 and the f file really am gets
gets dangerous it's some for example if
black gum recaptures let's say here rook
takes Bishop f5 first you think okay
this isn't useful terrible but why do I
just drop the Queen back and it's not at
all clear how this should should unfold
it's super complicated widest on the
king with a couple of pieces and it's
not not clear how to continue let's say
this move just for it for example is
it's not good but let's just have a look
at this black grab this there's this
possibility attacking the bishop and
let's say this kind of defense at the
end white will take here and still
retains an attack against the king it
simply this King has no squares I mean
this is always a huge indicator that
you've got problems if your king is
boxed in and white has various ideas to
to strengthen this so it's very tricky
already capturing only three is really
am it's really risky at the end he
decided
to take on f5 with the with the G porn
and white of course this was the idea
group tanks f5 you're not here to
hesitate anymore but yeah okay yeah it's
pretty easy to see this move um if black
would take now then Queen f5 simply
checkmates very briefly you can you can
give a check here but now it's it's
simply over Queen f7 major sir it's
unavoidable so black cannot take this
and here in this position he decided to
actually grab the pond and this is
probably probably the right decision um
y playthrough f2 and then f5 yeah what
else you need to cover this area h7 this
mate and now rugae three so already
you'll notice white has some some really
active pieces those are our active and
f5 very much weakened e6 so there are
ideas with 96 and this is what happens
Queenie seven and 96 of course you
cannot take care about the diss epona on
me two or something you need to get
going 96 also now attacking f5 with
Queen and rook so it's very very
difficult for black to not take the
night here he took it it I think you you
have no choice you need to get rid of
this piece and then he played them
Bishop to deform yeah obviously the idea
that like as following is to exchange
pieces and their form yeah make the
defense a bit easier but white really
doesn't care hot material anymore he
didn't play Bishop e3 which is playable
it's not a bad move he took on f5 really
going for it and giving up the the
exchange on f2 and black gum black took
at them it's it's not much else you need
to need to grab this yeah and now have a
look at this
position White has those three attacking
units are great at the pawn of course is
also an attacking attacking piece here
Lex king is really in trouble it doesn't
have any any good good scores to go to
very unsafe and lack of quake can give a
check but wyd simply drops back end is
secure with the king so what should like
do to defend this position I think he
played the probably the best move 97 you
can always consider taking so let's say
here here and then play 97 but the
problem is a bit that this rook is loose
it's not covered and a move like bishop
reform gets really tricky this is the
threat with the tempo on the rook and
this in fact has already lost would like
he has no move it's really curious this
bedrock position costs the game if black
plays something like this you'll go here
and like his tell us he cannot take only
six and something like this simply loses
York so taking on on b2 with checkers
probably a bad idea 97 was played I
think this is right it's correct and now
rook to e3 covering the important
attacking porn yeah this is probably the
critical position and here nida CH went
wrong and lost the game as a consequence
not so easy to see but um here's the
critical position probably should play
night we ate this move it's not like the
most obvious move ever but this covers
those squares and this seems to be
better White has a really really good
attack for the material and I'm not 100%
sure that this really holds the game
um I would need to put in more time to
to really figure out if this holds our
online if it loses as well I think this
is the only move that really makes it
difficult forum for white a possibility
just the sample line which would draw
and this shows that on white has enough
in this position is this move
threatening queen of a double check made
and something like this here I'm not
saying this is the best for white but it
shows that why does probably okay you
can even get in this into this end game
and now rupee seven with the idea Bishop
g5 and this is probably a draw um yeah
black will need to sacrifice one one
exchange back you cannot play play on
without this so something like this um
this is simply so strong that black
needs to return and exchange and it
could it could continue like this just
sample line and this is probably good
enough for a draw it's not the best best
line for white this rook f3 this one but
I'm just would just to prove that why
this okay is some it's good for me at
the moment so you could really look if
white has something better than this
move maybe he has it's it's really
dangerous okay night it's played rook to
e8 and this fails curiously enough to
Bishop e3 with this really direct idea
Bishop h5 Bishop f7 yeah like a hockey
puck every h5 f72 to the to the to the
goal here and ya know black is lost if
you look at this a bit a bit further
you'll see that black really has has no
defense he played look f8 we can look at
some other ideas if black
let's let's start with this white can
simply grab on on e6 and Queenie six
should be five probably will get at
least there will the Queen and probably
it will end in checkmate because the
king is so open um so black cannot take
on e6 can always consider this rugby too
but I don't think it helps much let's um
let's have a quick look and now I what
should black do a mini it doesn't have
any moves big moves anyway if he doesn't
nothing move let's say he plays b6 which
doesn't do anything really then there's
this move coming and let's say here you
just take it and this ends in checkmate
it's simply a super strong crease on f7
like has no no defense at all so it's
pretty pretty typical that the piece
that in relatively speaking is the the
one that is not taking part in two in
the attack so much as the other so Queen
Bishop and so on this is on g2 it's not
doing so much it's very typical that
activating this really decides if you
manage to get in all your pieces you
often break through so we should have
three now wins the game with this funny
maneuver yeah 90 displayed rook f8 last
Drive why took on a fade Queen f8 clue
g5 check king 2 h8 not much choice if
you would play Queen to g7 you've got
this move coming this is pretty pretty
typical winning of winning the game
so um in the game after Queen D 1 2 h8
now is seven the past ponies strong
obviously yeah like I would lock it you
simply have this move oops not this move
this one and you push the Queen away and
promote so we went here yeah now White
has a very neat finish it's not
difficult but still nice q8 queen with a
check Knight takes root eggs and here
knowledge resigned in view of Queen
takes only move Queen a6 check came here
we should five check and yeah Black has
only got some desperado moves like this
chutney and mate on alternatively Queen
f6 also checkmate yeah so very nice game
which shows that 300 raging difference
doesn't necessarily mean that the
favorite on paper will always win the
game but you need to really grab your
chances and if you if you got some
activity going you need to push on and
this white really really did very well
in this game so well deserve to win here
in this club competition yeah I hope you
enjoyed the game and I'll maybe look at
some more games from this from this
event as I think that's often very
interesting chess being played down also
because of this kind of sometimes uneven
match ups I think they're probably have
been some other upsets but this is what
i just found quickly when i browse
through the games yeah i hope you
enjoyed it and i'll be back soon with
new stuff